you you to the broad city gals do
shrooms
in an episode do you base the master in
mushrooms for those of you who don't
know the abbreviated shrooms yeah okay
fungi mushroom you guys ingest mushrooms
for their psychedelic effect and you I'm
curious if that's based on real-life
experience is that you want to share
anything with us about that
I have believe it or not I like the yay
you did it you did mushrooms I did but I
have been on a I might been on a slow
decline since high school really from
drug use yeah I partake but yes I do
less and less I don't smoke as much as
as my character that's the interesting
thing is that you guys play characters
that smoke for example a ton of weed and
yet that's not really your thing when
you meet fans do they are they surprised
or maybe even disappointed that you
don't partake as much as your character
I mean I do a little and if when you
have a lot of weird backwards broglie
living now where you're defensive
because you feel that you're living to
responsibly
that's the world right now when you have
a lot on this might be a different
conversation but I okay got it
yeah I don't I think it might be a
little disappointing mm-hmm I know I'm
not as wild as she is yeah I'm more wild
in the productivity Department I really
get down in the writers room yeah
actually I can relate to when I was in I
was in college and I walked into a good
I was walked into a room and people were
doing cocaine and I didn't do anything
I've never really done anything and I
walked through means people were doing
cocaine and one of them looked up and
he's like hey man you want to do some
blow and I said no my father's a doctor
and he says it interferes with the heart
rhythm yeah yeah I lost my virginity two
years ago
you